songs already how high are you
yeah they still got peep shows really
they got one up here and uh i eat
sandwiches across the street what's the
place up here aroma um lancashire's got
a great [ __ ] sandwich for lunch grape
sandwich
sandwich two sides and a soda for like
six bucks and i'd go in there with the
wife before she got pregnant we had the
kid and across the street from there i
was talking to the kids or armenians it
used to be an italian deli but it became
armenian and uh i asked him once what is
that a strip club and he goes no the
strip club is like four blocks down it's
a filthy strip club because this place
across the street is where you go in and
talk to a chick in a booth
that's naked or some [ __ ]
that's a peep show that's a peep show
that's a puerto rican peep show oh i
kept thinking it was the
you know when you go in and just shows
the dirty movies
and you just go in and watch in the
theater like with a bunch of other dudes
that i thought that was a peep show well
that's like a porno theater do they
still have those anybody know if they
still have like old pornography thieves
they gotta have them in new york they
gotta have a few in new york i didn't
see one
at like an actual theater but like like
a sex store had like up some video
places in the back right then you go in
the back and sit in a booth and then
they have the videos you wipe off in
there that's yeah
that's for a quick tug you're driving
down the 405 you feel like wacking off
but you got too much class to do in your
car
you pull over some orange building with
some iranian dude with a missing eye
with a little hat on with a dodger hat
on
you go in there you get a couple tokens
you go in the back room and they usually
put them in there you sit down it smells
like [ __ ] debt yeah because now as a
kid i would go to the ones on 42nd
stream there's two types of peep shows
there's the peep show where the woman's
in the [ __ ] middle whacking off and
she's all [ __ ] up degenerate looking
like this is going at the end of their
shift so we would play hooky in jersey
right a sixth seventh grade we'd get
over there like maybe 10 30 by 10 30 we
catch
the chicks that did speed the night
before it wasn't meth like they did
black beauties they got [ __ ] like 10
000 times but then they go in there for
like six bucks an hour in tips because
they got to work the gank off they don't
have to suck a dick but they just go in
there and lay there and play with that
[ __ ] and the [ __ ] would be [ __ ] all
[ __ ] up some people go to the
mountains and the mountains throw them
the [ __ ] off
seattle buffalo new york has a weird
effect on people it's up there high it's
very cloudy some people i'm telling you
so and and you know there's people at
home listening going joy what the [ __ ]
you do i i believe and the thing with
seattle was that uh i spoke to somebody
one time they said bremerton
bremerton washington which is uh 45
minutes outside seattle yeah is a navy
base it's one of those bases i'm sorry i
don't know i think it's a navy if i'm
correct but they have the submarines
that shoot out to the rest of the world
the reason why the submarines are there
is because it's the deepest point in the
united states where the submarines can
go down a lot of people don't know look
it up on repeat i'm dropping knowledge
on you [ __ ] here that's why
they have the subs that's the lowest
point and you know in my mind yeah joey
you're a [ __ ] up guy you were doing
coke and drugs and eating a [ __ ]
stripper sure you got bad luck coming
your way and i thought that that part of
it was her bad luck cause she was a
[ __ ] thief a strip is nothing but a
[ __ ] thief oh yeah yeah they're
[ __ ] thieves i love them i respect
what they do they're out there they're a
thief without a gun their gun is their
[ __ ] snatch and that's how they get
you and they're taking the [ __ ]
hundreds of dollars and hey i've been a
victim i was in the halfway house
sometimes selling blow and i bumped into
a korean with fake tits that was banging
i gave her everything i snorted but i
had my hand in her [ __ ] like deep in
her ass was she a she though because the
kareem with fake tits you got your hand
drinking i was eating a [ __ ] at the
strip club oh nice i was in the halfway
house i was two months from getting
married i didn't give a [ __ ] at that
time i was 28 years old 29 i had already
done time i didn't give a [ __ ]
i went in there so i understand it i get
the whole mentality but the stripper the
mentality is a taker for you you're a
[ __ ] trick
you're a trick hey baby yeah well i'm
going to college
i'm supporting my dad he's wounded he
was a vet
you know i'm just here i haven't done
this i'm single he just broke up with me
yeah we'll hook up you want to know let
the lap dance here we're going to in the
back room where things happen in the
back room what's it cost a hundred
[ __ ] dollars and next thing you know
you're down to buck 20 and all you got
was your dick rubbed through the [ __ ]
jeans you could have done that yourself
with a fake hand
and save money all you would have paid
for shipping and handling right or wrong
it's through the jeans too it's uh yeah
it's it's a it's a wild life i thought
part of the bad karma was living with
that [ __ ] freak
but who knew who knew what was going on
you know you had some bad luck up there
what now you were you were drafted by
the seahawks yeah i was drafted and so
you went up there everything was
beautiful the sun only shines in the
summertime
[ __ ] october comes it's rainy as [ __ ]
what were you thinking
the i wasn't really thinking about the
weather initially because it didn't wear
on me yet i was so into like i'm playing
ball and and then i'm partying on my
free time you know what i mean and
sometimes waiting while i'm playing ball
like all right i gotta get out of here i
gotta go you know it's time to go out
and this whole thing but uh i got into
running with them
uh the cops uh in bellevue
and uh i'm at a bar there's this bar
called the munch bar right just this
like that was where the football players
were going at this time it was in
bellevue
and i walk outside and i'm you know
i'm pissed drunk literally
and i go into like a little like side
little alleyway and it's in this really
it's bellevue so it's it's rich town
right it's like in this really like nice
uh little mall strip area and the bars
in there
and i'm taking a piss out on the side
and one of these like mall cop guys sees
me right and he grabs me and he's like
you're he's like you're you're banned
you're never allowed to come back here
and i'm like oh okay sure and he writes
me like a legitimate like a ban like a
writ you know old ass 1970s you know
like and signs it and gives it to me and
i just threw it away same thing
and uh
i come back because that's where
everybody went right so next time i come
back with one of my buddies and this
dude's like freaking he's got like four
inches on me three inches on me and
another 30 pounds just a huge dude
and uh we're outside uh of one of the
mall places and they had already seen me
the security guards had seen me in the
mall and then called the cops and like
ratted me out
so i'm outside when these places i'm
smoking a j with this guy and uh the cop
rolls right up on us
like right pull the car that car right
there and we're like oh [ __ ] no so we
throw it
and we just start running right and
we're just trucking it and i'm wearing
like freaking like moccasins and like
whatever and he's a huge dude and
honestly i feel like we're running like
a [ __ ] like a four three forty like
just
flying because i feel like they're gonna
tase me you know they have the new
tasers with the um
they can shoot you from far away and
that like all cops are carrying these
tasers so i'm like really feeling like
i'm gonna get tased so my back's tight
and i'm like running as fast as i can we
ripped through this apartment that he
still had a key to
they used to live in so we we think
we're good we're gonna beat him here
right because the main door takes a key
cop catches the door and he's still
running after us in the hallway then we
did like the old split up at the end of
the hallway where i went out the back
exit door he went up the stairs right
and then we just go and i'm hiding in
the bushes the cops are driving by i've
lost them now the cops are driving by
can hear all their [ __ ] and i call an
uber actually and have them meet me in
the corner and run into the uber jump in
and get out of there right so i evaded
them again
and i just kept going back there because
i thought it was a joke i thought it was
actually kind of fun it was like [ __ ]
them whatever they didn't catch me like
who cares they're not fast
so called a getaway car for uber from
uber yeah
like an uber black right it was uber
black yeah and the guy loved it the guy
like was all about it i jumped in the
back and he could tell there was like
this sense of urgency and i was talking
i'm like look man i'm like i'm not gonna
lie to you we gotta get the hell out of
here you're gonna shut uber down dude
and he just and he loved it he's like i
got you don't worry i got you i'm like
thanks i appreciate that and so uh the
third time they finally got me and it
was like i felt like [ __ ] i felt like
[ __ ] john gotti because i'm sitting
at this restaurant i'm eating dinner and
i got my buddies with me and i think a
couple girls meet my girlfriend and uh
and uh
i see this cop out of the corner of my
eye walk in and i'm like oh [ __ ] and i
instantly reactionally look out the back
door to see if i can run there right
another cop right there and so i was
surrounded clearly and the worst is they
get me they bring me outside it's like a
busy [ __ ] night in bellevue
everyone's there watching i got you know
the cuffs you know they do the whole
thing they read me my rights do you
understand they bring the paddy wagon
because i'm too big for the car
so they brought a paddy wagon and loaded
me into the paddy wagon
and every time i get arrested now the
few times i have i'm always in a paddy
wagon because i'm too [ __ ] big for
the cop car so they gotta wait and they
gotta call this giant you know short bus
for prisoners and i gotta go ride on
that thing to jail and that's that was
the experience now you get out the next
day who's on the phone with you first i
gotta call pete i call well i get out
yeah and i call pete and uh and i call
tom cable up immediately cause i'm like
i'm gonna beat them i'm beating this to
the punch right here
and pete actually like
he kind of laughed a little because he
was like really like
for pissing like that's what they that's
what they wanted you for it was amazing
how serious they guessed
crazy serious crazy
and they were they honestly i got into
some [ __ ] in chicago and they were
easier on me in chicago which was way
worse than they were in bel the bellevue
judge was so serious i was more worried
about bellevue which was nothing than i
was it was crazy they probably just
don't have much
it's like they have to make a big deal
out of it or else king county jail is a
real [ __ ] it's it's there's some real
[ __ ] crazy people up there that
weather makes you react a weird way
so everything's [ __ ] weird but
it's amazing where the biggest cities
because they have more going on
their police programs a little bit more
lenient they'll listen to your story a
little more
they'll turn you around they'll take you
to the station say listen
we found we on there and we found little
glow we looked at your record you're not
a bad guy we're gonna make believe the
blow didn't exist and you're sitting
there going okay
i can live with this you're a nice
person just get out man all right
exactly son your age the guy will talk
to you they'll throw the weed on you
they'll kick this they'll get rid of the
warrant
it's it's it's
when you show respect and you act kindly
towards the cops
but seattle there was they were like
machines
yeah they were like machines they didn't
want to listen we're here to arrest you
what do you mean you know
well the lane next door said one time i
went on a monday i don't know if you
know josh wolfe
now
uh chelsea lately i i was his roommate
yeah i've heard of a man and we were
roommates and one day on a monday i go
he goes what are you going to do that i
go nothing because you want to hit
ecstasy i got one left over this show i
had in my pocket i was going to do it
the weekend but i go down to [ __ ]
swanies there's some people down it's
like 11 in the morning people are
drinking yeah people talking about
getting a package what the [ __ ]
i got i got 12 bucks let me do a [ __ ]
shot and yeah lie to people and do a
[ __ ] hit of ecstasy and all of a
sudden the x calls me the stripper she
pages me
and she goes come down i miss you i
[ __ ] run i just did x i'm ready to
get my dick stuck
i get a cab i go right to [ __ ] how
tie beach
and i get in the thing i rip our clothes
off we get on the bed we start [ __ ]
next you know boom boom boom boom boom
she had the police she told the [ __ ]
neighbor she saw me to call the cops the
cop sees and they come to the door
there's a restraining order still we
both have on each other
but no that time i hit under the bed
that's the time i hit under the bed
naked and they drew their guns out
because i was so fat the bed kept going
up and down
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah they can't over that
over that they arrested me that time
they [ __ ] took me out of the house
shirtless
they [ __ ] up my shoulders i started
getting off on the x while i was getting
fingerprinted this is [ __ ] chris
seattle for me
was 18 months of [ __ ] craziness yeah
but then guess what happens
one christmas [ __ ] week with comedy
slow as [ __ ]
that week that dad like a shitty
headliner come in friday instead of
thursday night
and they had local comics go up on
wednesday and thursday and do like
and i was one of the guys they picked
him one of the craziest things happened
and all this madness
guy goes joe diaz my name is whatever
chuck was his name really nice [ __ ]
guy
he was like i need to talk to you about
some because i'm executive producer of a
show named bronx county
and we got what's his name to direct
some big time director he ended up on
the sopranos as an actor
and he goes we're going to have this cop
show and we really want you to play the
bartender this is a true story and i'm
like
this happens to people in l.a
this isn't and the guy's like uh we're
going to call you january 3rd
give us your info and get your plane
ticket to come down and read for it if
everything works out we'll pay for the
move the whole thing i mean
so at the end of that whole 18-month
[ __ ] that's what came up yeah and
then as i was gonna leave
seattle
i got a letter in the mail like i was
ready to shoot at this thing i'm like
yeah come down i get a letter in the
mail i gotta go to court friday for
probation violation
and they're like no they're gonna throw
you in for nine months
and i went there and told the judge the
truth and he goes this one might do
get the [ __ ] out of seattle don't come
back for two or three [ __ ] years take
the anger management classes and get
your life together good luck but don't
ever come back he's like you're like
banned from the [ __ ] state
and that was it that was 1997 and 98 i
never went back it was two years of hell
on top of the three i had just gone
through boulder with the ex-wife and the
kid yeah and they won the [ __ ]
stabber in the neck and all that [ __ ] so
seattle is weird man seattle is a weird
place it really is
now you're going through all this [ __ ]
playing football that must be even
weirder listen man when you walk in here
i'm an east coast guy i grew up with
crazy kids
and i know you never sweetheart of a guy
but you're the type of guy when you go
you go you're an offensive lineman yeah
go you go you [ __ ] are crazy
you know what it is you you get really
good at the double life you know what i
mean you get really good at like playing
like like and obviously everyone knew
like in football like i was a partier
but you get good at like
you don't know how i party maybe i just
drink beer but really you know you're in
the party life you're doing whatever you
want to do
and uh and then you come to football and
you do that [ __ ] hard as hell
and you're good you know i mean it's
like both both sides of the what it does
it wears on you you know it gets like
this shit's kind of hard i mean i'm not
stopping but this [ __ ] is really kind of
hard doing both you know how to catch a
nap if i want to get pick up that g-boat
thing
and see the [ __ ] devil
it's uh
my whole thing that i realized seven
eight years after not doing powder and
[ __ ]
i still smoke dope i love it it calms me
down if i didn't smoke i'd stab people
no and uh
the thing that always bothered me about
doing drugs
that people
at it's it people add the blame to drugs
for a lot of things and for me it wasn't
the [ __ ] i did on the drugs
it's my behavior off the drugs that was
always
for me when i was on drugs you don't see
me i didn't do drugs in [ __ ] public
i stopped doing coke in public in 1994
after 94 93 i was in the dungeon jack
i already had beer there i had food for
the next morning i had everything so you
wouldn't see me at all in that condition
the only person would see me in that
condition if i called the woman at like
two in the morning
to come over and i get cleaned up for
her to come open yeah back off i'd take
a shower and wash my [ __ ]
you know you gotta get cleaned up from
me i'd eat the inside of an orange and
does that work they always said i used
to know this colombian guy in jersey
called loco that used to carry coke and
leaves
in 84 he used to [ __ ] get that we
were kids inside of a he always had coke
inside of leaves coca leaves he would go
right to colombia and come back and he'd
have the leaves with the coke in the
[ __ ] leaves even though it was
illegal now it's big people in the
states are bringing coca leaves and
having them chewing them and they're
chewing them up in the hills of [ __ ]
hollywood they pay like 2 000 for a
[ __ ] leaf no [ __ ] people give them a
leaf you know what i just heard about
and it was like close to making me
really excuse me relapse was uh [ __ ]
pink coke have you heard of this [ __ ]
pink cocaine apparently pink cocaine is
like the big the biggest thing right now
it's like the purest [ __ ] you can right
that's how it started out in the 80s it
was [ __ ] pink it was all pink it was
beautiful i've never even seen pink
cocaine oh
i'm writing this chapter now just
[ __ ] around to because sometimes when
you're writing something you focus too
much on what you're writing on so what i
did was i i got a side chapter and and
that's it it was just cocaine
and i talk about how you know i start
like people you know people in this
country do not want to believe this
everybody always says no marijuana is
not a gateway drug i'm [ __ ] sorry
i got this party started because i
smoked a joint and hurt paranoid yeah
and that's it after you hit pat then you
put on led zeppelin
uh for enough for the one with the
[ __ ] house of the holy on and the
ocean and all that [ __ ] i was done i was
gone i was gone after that so if that
sounded that good on reefer
how would it and i started experimenting
with micro dot acid you weren't even
itching your dad what is that [ __ ] like
because i always think of what the old
uh lsd was well i would mess around with
these little micro dots
they were adopted a little dot
and purple brown
blue green it all came in weird colors
and it would just jizz you out but you
were hallucinating
and some people said it was rap boys and
whatever listen
some people i [ __ ] put i [ __ ]
tripped my ass off i tripped my ass off
i loved it so much like at that at one
point i was just no way before i had
done that [ __ ] for about a year i
experimented me and my friends on friday
nights would take it and walk around
and we would drink three beers i was
maybe
14. yeah we drink three beers like an
eight pack between three of us yeah
that's normal and then we tripped for
like [ __ ] 10 hours and we went home
and i'd watch uh like i had like the the
map of the envy of the mcdonald's
all-star all-american team on my wall
michael korin and they started like
going
yeah i had a picture of julius irving
dunking like and he didn't move he
didn't stop and go high how are you no
it's never like that's just a thing yeah
and then after that in the eighth grade
i got [ __ ] zapped
my friend vinnie lynch god blesses so he
was like three or four years older than
me he said you wanna i gotta get he goes
i makes a ticket
this is why i treat you like i duly say
it okay because there's no [ __ ]
coming back
he took me down to philadelphia to see
the rolling stones
this is the summer of 80 [ __ ] this is
the summer of 78 they just put out that
whoo i'm in the [ __ ] eighth grade i'm
gonna be a freshman in high school
because you want i got a free ticket for
you come far and i was the opening act
we drove to philadelphia he got a hotel
room a bunch of us went in the [ __ ]
they were like 16 17 i was 13.
a bunch of my buddies went because we
had they had older brothers they took
care of us and one night vinnie lynch
came in he goes listen man i got
windowpane acid and that was the devil
like battered the [ __ ] good [ __ ] that
was it was that and the [ __ ] they put in
your eyes i hadn't done it they killed
my eyes so first i did the window pane
acidly and it was like the way you feel
this is why what are they putting in
your eyes
no hold on we'll get to that later and
pane acid
and i think it took like 40 minutes
and it started and it cooked this thing
cooked right away like right away you
heard [ __ ]
it got low in the room it got high the
lights would turn down
like your eyes would dilate and the
color in the lighthouse and that light
would turn blue
that blue from the israeli flag would
get really strong and it would dominate
the room and also in all three of us we
got to go out and i remember going
downstairs in the elevator and that was
the first time
i thought my head was really really
going to blow up at the age of 13.
like i just come back from basket from
from [ __ ] five-star basketball camp
with athletes with dominique wilkins as
a counselor
and here i am with these long-haired
[ __ ] rock new jersey
[ __ ] dropping the windowpane acid and
they take me into that [ __ ] uh
outside thing wherever the philadelphia
i don't want to give names because then
i i forget the name of these auditoriums
and people [ __ ] chastise me on
twitter it was the it was where the
[ __ ] eagles played
and we went in there and the [ __ ]
stuff and he came out with like an
american flag on him or some [ __ ] and
i'm tripping my balls off thinking this
guy's not even [ __ ] american he's
[ __ ] english but i don't give a [ __ ]
take that and he was just great it was
something and after that we went to with
his moat philadelphia in those days had
like a like think of how [ __ ] crazy
we were like what could be in that water
yeah like there was a street and then on
the streets you know you have those
little islands in the middle of the
streets streets are going this way
streets are going that way yeah and you
have that thing in the middle they had
little things with water in them we
jumped in it like it was [ __ ] a river
that thing could have lice and leech in
it and [ __ ]
that's a lot worse than him
but that
but that acid trip was in my mind it was
20 hours late
20 hours of light change and you pissing
and thinking nothing's coming out of my
dick and then you can walk out
and that was those were the best
tripping years you're a kid you're a
[ __ ] kid and you you're just giggling
and also like i would call you we'd say
look
joey i'm playing football and my
brother's a [ __ ] cop don't say
nothing but i want to try acid but take
care of me like go you i got you john
yeah yeah
and we go to a party we only you and i
knew we were tripping and you go talk to
girls and i go talk to lee but this is
why i love this because every like 18
minutes on the minute
i turn around and you turn around and we
make eye contact and go and go right
back
that's the whole that's why
when you make that connection yeah
that's why you can't wait to do it again
that's rare now that's rare these days
because i always tripped like alone a
lot of times and i'd be the guy going
out like alone like i'm tripping and it
doesn't ground you at all like that's a
great grounding tool because you can
look at the guy and be like we got this
we're together when you're alone
tripping you're like oh my god maybe
that you listen to people's [ __ ] and
you're like oh man i'm not hearing it
correctly maybe i'm wrong this is not
good this is getting overwhelming this
is too much i got really mushrooms with
nothing
i'm from the east coast like you right
growing up on the east coast we weren't
introduced to mushrooms
we didn't have uh sativa weed from
california i grew up with brown wheat
from jamaica yeah
and then we didn't have a lot of things
i got introduced to mushrooms in aspen
colorado 4th of july
1983 john denver was [ __ ] playing at
the children's foundation and i got some
mushrooms and went to a bridge and i
loved the feeling but i didn't like the
diarrhea yeah i didn't like to go into
the bathroom my [ __ ] feels weird is
that toilet paper stuck to my ass i
didn't get that a lot maybe that's the
first time thing
yeah
when you do mushrooms some people react
their stomachs are not like i said that
thing you're inside the [ __ ] toilet
the [ __ ] and thinking how many trees
that they cut down you get that toilet
paper i swear to god that's what i was
thinking about i'll never forget that
that's why i didn't like it how strong
were the things you gave me a few months
ago like those were soaked ones from
indianapolis the mushrooms yeah they
were cause i i never like hallucinated
no we didn't it felt like a light weave
okay they didn't give me enough to
hallucinate so small amounts of it are
awesome then it's even better than weed
yeah i think large amounts are awesome
i think the only way to really that's
the terence mckenna like do a large
amount of this [ __ ] and really get
what's that
four
his thing was five grams
and i did it once
i did five grams right before i [ __ ]
did right before rehab i i was like i'm
going to rehab this [ __ ] sucks i was in
my house in seattle i was gonna come
down to malibu and uh my girlfriend left
for the day and no one was in the house
and i was like all right i got all these
i had like eight grams of mushrooms so
i'm like i'm like listening to terence
mckenna and he's like you got to do the
recommended dose it's like five grams
and then you'll really it'll change your
universe i'm like [ __ ] it all right
so i do like five maybe leaning on six
and i uh you know you eat it and then
you're kind of just playing the waiting
game but you try not to think about it
right
and he's like doing he's like this is so
intense you need to be ready and you
need to start singing songs and [ __ ] and
get your mind like in the right place so
i'm alone singing songs in my smoke room
right
and uh
you know it's like been i don't know how
long that's the name of your book that's
right yeah i'm singing alone singing
songs in my smoke room so
i'm i'm you know in my mind it's been a
long time and i'm like i'm like all
right i'm gonna i'm gonna get ready for
the day i'm gonna take a shower and get
it it's 11 in the morning so
when i started i'm thinking it's around
you know afternoon it's time to get out
take a shower i get dressed i get all
dressed and ready everything's ready to
go i'm looking in the mirror i'm
throwing darts getting ready i look in
the mirror
um like you're good time to go out look
at the clock it's [ __ ] been 20
minutes it has been 20 minutes and the
trip hasn't even started yet and i'm
already like on the moon and after that
it was like a
it was one of the like
scary and the most thrilling experiences
of my life i mean absolutely horrifying
to the point where like maybe i'll never
be the same again but then at the same
time like the excitement of like maybe
i'll never [ __ ] be the same again
it's a it's
there's a different mindset to tripping
and doing that type of stuff when you're
younger
i mean you're an offensive lineman
i don't know any [ __ ] like yeah you
either meet a christian offensive
lineman
or they're out of their [ __ ] mind
okay you either meet a christian and
very or they're out of their minds and
that's how they have to be in their job
i don't know their job but they're
blocking [ __ ] guerrillas all day
they're blocking men that are
you know that they made it to the nfl
they all do for two [ __ ] forties
strong [ __ ] strong as [ __ ] you know
it's it was something that i could never
imagine at the professional level i mean
and you started at a young age with
football yeah it's about eight eight
years old yeah and you were all american
all american in college yeah the whole
thing yeah third round drafted and uh i
was in wisconsin four years oh my god
five years in wisconsin five years red
shirted
greatest time of my life that's where i
learned to drink that's where i really
learned how to drink like the right way
like you know you don't stop and uh
oh my god wisconsin was you know what's
uh i was just talking to my uh my
quarterback scott tolzien and he's with
the green bay packers now
and i was like he was giving me all the
old stories because i
i literally forget like 80 percent of
that [ __ ] that went down there you know
that's what college is for
yeah this dude was losing college
this was my he was my roommate and he
was like the straight edge you know
quarterback you know what i mean and he
remembers he remembers all of it and i
was saying i'm like scott man i'm so
glad you were so lucid throughout
college or else this would have all been
lost all of this i don't remember
remember maybe five to ten stories all
around games or wins and then the rest
is just
just at a bar it's all the same scene at
a bar
you won a championship up there we won a
big ten championship and then we went to
the rose bowl i [ __ ] believe it yeah
the rose bowl what a feeling is that as
a
when we won um
we beat northwestern and we won the big
ten championship and everybody rushes
the field they're [ __ ] losing their
mind and then they're like we're going
to the rose bowl we found that one out
the roses are everywhere i didn't remove
a rose from my [ __ ] face for like 24
hours right and then the town like is
the first one rose bowl in 15 years and
the town's like losing their mind
and uh
so we go out and we're partying and i'm
in this place called the essen house and
there's these boots of beer right
and everyone's there we're all just
getting freaking shitty
i'm talking to this professor
at wisconsin and we're talking about
he's like a science professor so we're
talking about the universe and all this
[ __ ] right
and we get so deep into it we turn
around and all my boys are gone they
went to the next bar right so the
professor he's like i'm like hey
professor do you want to come to the
next bar with us we'll continue the
conversation about the universe he's
like he's like of course
and uh so i got a freshman with me and
we all go out and the bouncer i'm
leaving i know the bouncer is like maf
he's like you know that guy's totally
[ __ ] up right i'm like he's fine he's
a scientist
guys like the guy he's like fine good
luck taking your future in your hands
i'm like man [ __ ] you so we get in the
car and we're driving down the street
right and i'm still this the the car is
like fogged out like so you can imagine
what it smells like in there but the
windows are fogged right and it's
wisconsin middle of winter it's freezing
ass cold
all of a sudden the berries go up behind
us and we get pulled over and i'm like
what the [ __ ] could be going wrong the
cops come up
this is the same night we had our
christmas party so we're all wearing
like tight ass likes like you know
christmas fruity christmas sweaters and
[ __ ]
and the one cop two female cops one
comes to the right side there goes to
his side right and the other one she
pulls him out and she's giving him the
sobriety test okay and i know we're
[ __ ] so i'm looking at the cop and i'm
like listen i'm like i don't even know
this guy
so we're good right i didn't know the
rule she's like yeah you're not driving
you you know you're an idiot you're fine
like oh thank god because i was planning
to run right i was telling the freshmen
we're going to run you know the usual
[ __ ] scientist gets back in the car
three minutes later right looks at him
in the eyes i swear to christ he was
cross-eyed and he goes i passed the eye
exam
and they let us go
and they [ __ ] let us go all the way
down the rest of the one-way road into
the next bar and that same night another
one of my buddies got picked up by the
cops in a snowbank in the road and they
just brought him back to his house no
one said [ __ ] the whole town was like
whatever you want to do you can do it
yeah
yeah
so now it's your senior year yeah you
know you're getting drafted you have an
agent everybody's knocking on your
[ __ ] door yeah what teams are you
looking at originally so they they it's
totally
on
the teams like you have no um
i mean who was the last guy uh eli
manning was the last guy to say oh [ __ ]
this i'm going to the giants right but
since then no one says
[ __ ] like the team picks you based on
you know your draft position your value
that's it so when i got i got a call
like a week before the draft from
seattle
and they were like hey do you have any
um qualms about coming to seattle
and i was like
all right i saw our side of the [ __ ]
country yeah no that sounds good and
then sure enough they drafted me that
was it they didn't ask me [ __ ] we're at
the combine they didn't even interview
me everyone else you got freaking uh
jeff ireland from the miami dolphins
he's asking me if i'm an alcoholic and
[ __ ] how many problems i have why i'm so
fat all the time like sometimes i'm like
three thirty three four are you weighing
now 290. you look great thank you thank
you 340 when you're in college oh yeah
yeah you got to be there yeah you
[ __ ] pay your [ __ ] run
around and tackle [ __ ] that's
what i said and i said and i accept a
drink good amount i eat a lot of fried
food when i'm drinking
you're in college that's nice you know
you're a 24 year old you're a 22 year
old football player who's been [ __ ]
hitting it at nine to ten months a year
because in the summers you still lift
weights to be an all-american that
doesn't mean you sit there and scratch
your balls and muscles don't just
[ __ ] grow on you yeah you got to do
[ __ ] i remember just playing high school
ball in the [ __ ] we did in the summers i
can't move my my arms today because i'm
behind the neck presses in front of the
neck prices i'm done and i was just a
[ __ ] beyond i can't imagine the guy
that's an all-american you got to bang
it out so
22 year in college
your team is on the board everybody's
sucking your dick
right you're in college football listen
i was i watch eight minutes of [ __ ]
pro football a year anymore
i just don't have the time
and then i watch 10 minutes of college
ball
you know when you're a kid
and you're cuban and you come to this
country and you see college football on
sundays
oklahoma against alabama and you put on
they come out with a [ __ ] horse
first thing you see something i love to
play college football [ __ ] the pros
[ __ ] the pros the women's national
championship oh yeah and then to have a
regular career i could see it happening
oh yeah i could see that those guys that
do those 30 for 30s when the houston
when the north carolina team got
together and talked like that that's
friendship that's something that lasts
you never forget that you know
i i'm happy i still remember the kids on
my betty basketball team yeah you know i
mean we had a play in the eighth grade
called your mother that was the
emergency play because when you're
taking the ball out just saying your
mother just shocks everybody especially
from the east coast but your mother your
mother everybody was scrambled me and
these kids
uh you know we were like [ __ ] 0-9 in
basketball
in the 8th grade we all practiced hard
we got together in the summer we ran
plays there was this guy in the
neighborhood that played pro ball we got
him to come up and show us plays and he
showed us this [ __ ] easy basketball
thing he goes it always works
but you got a shot come on the gate you
got to come up with something like how
about your mother he's like that's
perfect it'll work
and we had this kid on the team he was
dominican but it was the east coast we
didn't care and after he was louis [ __ ]
he was dominic and we just called them
[ __ ]
it was louis [ __ ] me chucky mcbreen
good old time david ruiz and somebody
else is on that [ __ ] team
i don't even know what i'm talking about
i gotta stop eating these edibles
your mother your mother the point is
we had you know you built this bond even
at that level
even at that little kid level i'm sure
you played pee wee's they're still you
know my neighbor north bergen which is a
big football school oh yeah the coach
got rested so
they accused him he won the states of
going out and uh recruiting people in
high school which everybody was doing at
the time yeah they just wanted them and
don bosco right those are the two big
ones yeah yeah yeah
and then basketball the hurleys have
been doing it for 30 [ __ ] years when
i was in the eighth grade ladies and
gentlemen and talked to me yeah they
[ __ ] i went to superstar basketball
camp and they were like you should move
to jersey city oh just like that
what the [ __ ] jerseys yeah yeah so
now you're in seattle fresh year what's
going on you starting yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah i was starting yeah i started the
first eight games then blew my knee out
the ninth
yeah blew it like good like just cracked
in half like [ __ ] up like
did it so good that you know you're on
the ground you're like all right that'll
be a year that's just a year right there
you know and uh oh yeah yeah put it by
me and [ __ ] when i went out to see how i
was a rookie
and uh
it was awesome it was [ __ ] awesome it
kept there was just like this like uh
this period of time from i think it was
the winning you know when you win you
know what i mean like when we're seniors
you win win win win win all the way
through get into the nfl get drafted a
good place it was the lockout year if
you remember
so when i got so i wasn't
couldn't be talked to nothing right
after the draft until
like literally august 1st when we
started camp and i just showed up to
camp and then we were on
and then we did a month and then i mean
that [ __ ] was just fast like
learning i mean the nfl jump is is
like if the high school to college jump
is big the the college nfl jump is like
maybe right around the same or um
it's big it's a big jump first two weeks
of practice
after you've made the squad yeah so i
remember talking to my dad i remember
the the we had a
we had a day that it was like right
before we put out you know they ease you
into pads right so like you have three
days of nothing and then you have two
days of like half pads and then you go
full right
so like the third day of like notepads
like i was out there i remember calling
my dad after practice i'm like man i
think i can this shit's not you know i'm
doing good this is easy right
and like because my speed was good and
everything like that [ __ ] pads come
on
just like
a whole new level you know what i mean
whole new spirit and then you get that
it's a mind [ __ ] because you always
start thinking can i do this [ __ ]
so then the next literally the next day
we go on pads i'm just [ __ ] up get you
know
i mean you're a rookie you're getting
your ass kicked right
and then i'm doing that like oh my god
man i don't know if i am gonna and then
you kind of even out you adjust to the
speed you play some preseason games you
ball out a little and then it's on and
then every week is just like
the second you hit tuesday even sunday
after the game some guys are going but
like the second you hit tuesday it's
work your ass off you got tuesday
wednesday thursdays like a lighter day
friday's a walk through saturday's an
hour and then you're in at night and
then sunday's the game so it's really
fast and then when you're smoking dope
like every single day because i found
out i didn't do any smoking when i was
in college because it's like highly
illegal on ca testing like you can't
[ __ ] with that when i found out in the
pros that it's like the once a year
[ __ ] well i was right back on the
train
so i was doing the i like went right
back to like oh yeah go home study your
playbook and you're in seattle that rain
i grow some good [ __ ] reefer up there
jack
the whole thing the whole thing and it
was just i was right about we we knew it
was getting legal like it was we were
getting close because the year after
maybe two years after they completely
legalized it it sounds like you're like
a lot of free time so is it not i mean
not that you're not working hard you
probably get in there really early in
the morning but then you're probably out
of there by what four or five yeah and
then just have nothing to do all night
yeah
and i mean [ __ ] i'm a guy that goes to
sleep at like two
one no matter what so you have five to
one and then and then you're good
and then when you're on the road you
can't do anything like you just can't
you're stuck in the hotel room
so that's you know a lot of guys
actually go out a lot on the road
a lot of guys will get in like if you
get in on a friday guys will go out
friday night and some guys are crazy
enough to go out saturday night jesus
yeah there was a dude who got sent back
from the super bowl
yeah yeah offensive lineman oh my god
that happens i've i never i couldn't
understand it because i when i when we
traveled we went to the hotel like i'd
still sneak my [ __ ] on and i'd smoke it
like the night before or whatever and
then friday but i would never go out
never go out saturday night no hell no i
wouldn't even go out friday night i
wouldn't drink like i i knew drinking
was like the devil no movie no movie a
steak yeah you eat a nice you know i'd
rent a movie at the hotel room and eat a
nice dinner and the whole thing but like
like team provided all that [ __ ] but
guys were going out to drink
friday saturday night and like i would
hear about that champion like oh my god
how are you drinking the night before a
game or two nights before a game
but like some dudes it's just it's
amazing what dudes can you know
i mean listen showtime is
time show showtime is showtime you know
whatever the [ __ ] he did the night
before it all ends right there that's
why i made it to that [ __ ] level
exactly you know joe namath will go out
and get slide
the night before that's the run on the
street slash that's how people would
gamble in those days they'd go out on
saturday nights and they'd see how late
he'd stay out they'd follow him and then
they'd start making calls dog i'm at a
[ __ ] diner with joe namath he's still
snorting blow
bet against him right [ __ ] now you
know
he hasn't stopped he's gotten blown to
the table look the roberto duran just
walked in you know it was crazy so
that's how
that thing uh
and there's some guys it's funny i used
to work for a sports betting service
and the nights on friday night i would
go home because he cut you a deal he'd
say look we you go home friday at like
four
but if you stay till nine i'll put a
show on
and people will call and you guys get
those leads and i'll give you 150 cash
150 is all i need for an eight ball and
make dirty events deliver the ball right
to the [ __ ] office dirty vince i
wouldn't do a bump until i got that nine
i'd go home and get sloshed i wouldn't
do that last line we had to be in at
seven to sell college football on
saturdays i wouldn't be until seven i
would do the last line at 20 to [ __ ]
seven oh i'd be so coked up by going in
and just put tissue paper up my nose and
pitch
call people what's going on [ __ ]
grab your credit card do you know those
days i'd go in there whacked
i would do better than the other day of
the week because i was unconscious
in the zone man i was literally
unconscious so i was working the pitch
correctly i was working all my automatic
uh
you know like when you go back and forth
with people banter i don't know if it's
the same with sports i didn't play at
that professional type level i think it
is i really do i never
i guess maybe because offensive line or
whatever or how i felt i never risked
drinking too close to a game but when i
was in college and in the nfl during the
week we drink all week and so i'd come
into practice just you know like just
clear vodka sweat you know and you would
get into the zone where you'd be like
all right you know everything's all
[ __ ] up i'm [ __ ] up but i just got
to be right here right now and you think
like in that like incremental
little oh i got to do this right now and
honestly it puts you in the zone and
you're good and maybe that's what it's
like with a lot of guys that just [ __ ]
it you know so now you play there for a
season eight games you get
what happens you come back a year later
yeah came back a year later and uh kind
of went back and forth like was working
on the comeback so i was being like used
as like a utility guy which [ __ ]
pissed me off man because i was a i was
a player and they had a guy a good
friend of mine uh j.r sweezie they
converted him from d-line
so they were giving him a lot of chances
early on and i was being like really
steady the whole way through with a
[ __ ] up knee
um
so we we finished that year and the next
year i was getting so pissed off about
like getting jerked around i felt i went
into pete's room his office and i asked
him for a trade
i was like i think you should just trade
me i was like because i'm not gonna like
you know you you say that this is all
about competition but i think that's
[ __ ]
and you guys are playing favorites and i
think you should just get me out of here
because i'm not gonna be like the best
the trooper you know what i mean right
and he was basically like no that's you
know that's not the reality of things
and then it got i mean i kept them there
for like 30 minutes like i wouldn't like
i'm not gonna do like you're the boss
i'll just you know take it in the ass
and then be happy about it so i could
tell that really pissed him off right
so
he waited though for like the best time
to trade me which was [ __ ]
two weeks into camp my third year
two weeks into camp and he traded me to
the cleveland browns the shittiest team
ever right
and the [ __ ] up thing was i would
still be fine if it was the cleveland
browns because they sucked i would have
walked right in and started and been
good
um but they were [ __ ] around because
they didn't want to pay me my regular
contract so then they went in and they
tried to say there was something wrong
with my knee
so i'm in the browns i'm in the brown
thing and they they put me right when i
get in they fly me there first of all
they're like you're getting traded that
day that night they try to fly me out i
was like [ __ ] you guys i'll fly out in
the morning okay i'm not leaving tonight
i gotta pack i gotta do [ __ ] i have to
smoke ten blunts all my weeds here i
gotta figure out how i'm gonna get it
there i'm gonna call someone in
cleveland [ __ ] you
so
i get out there and they bring me right
to the hospital to mri me right to the
hospital don't even go to the team i go
right to the hospital i get mri i meet
with the doctor the doctor is actually
like a good doctor and says hey do you
want to meet you want to see your your
screenings your mri [ __ ] you want to see
your knee i was like i would
he shows me all of it he's like you got
arthritis that's normal
everything else looks fine you did a
good surgery you're paired up
everything's good right perfect go back
to the browns training camp my agent
calls he goes they want you to take half
of your contract
i said tell them to get [ __ ] like no
it's half my contract and i got traded
traded stays intact
so
they didn't like that they bring me up
like two hours later they bring me up to
the head the head coach and he's like
we're gonna we're gonna pass we're gonna
fail you on the physical
because your knee so it's a clever way
to avoid the trade right
and i was like well you can't do that
because i saw my mris and you're a
[ __ ] liar
so then he just walks out of the room
he just walks right out of the room and
he grabs uh i don't know where he went
right i love his mangini uh uh
chanovsky
the one right after him i think right
and uh so he goes and gets like the the
athletic trainer the guy that tapes
ankles and they bring me down to like
the president the gm like all the big
you know the big guys and we're sitting
in the conference room
and
he leaves and he's going to get like
another medical guy and i'm talking to
the gm or whatever and i'm like yo man
i'm like i don't know what you guys are
doing here
i get your offense i've watched some
film like i would love to play for you i
want to play i can play tomorrow like
like let's just stop the money's the
money i know you got it don't [ __ ] with
me you know
and they were like they were like hey
you're making a
honestly we don't know what's going on
because last night we said that's a
great addition to the team when we got
this trade
the other guy comes in and they try to
keep up with the medical thing and i
really get pissed off and this medical
guy that the ankle taper is like
here's he's trying to explain what's
wrong with my knee right so i let him do
his his feelings
and then i i go okay
this guy tapes [ __ ] ankles the doctor
show me the mris you guys are [ __ ]
lying it's all about money and we all
know that and that's [ __ ] stupid
because they're not in the position to
do this kind of [ __ ] over 300 000 and a
guard that you're getting for nothing
honestly i'm not i was on a third round
contract and the the new agreement it's
nothing and they let me walk right out
there and they traded me to denver
and that was it but after i was like
[ __ ] all of you [ __ ] the browns i wish
you the worst you're never gonna win the
end and then uh seattle picked me up and
brought me into denver this uh the gm
from seattle did me a salad and got me
into denver and then i'm with
[ __ ] peyton manning
every day and i'm high as [ __ ] in
practice because i'm like so i'm hating
life right now because i'm not gonna
play i'm not gonna start
and and denver's when it's getting
legalized so i got like all those
edibles i got the new i got these
morning mints that i'm taking on the way
in to work it's like a mint but it wakes
you up it's a sativa kind of upper we
wake up [ __ ]
look at the shape of this [ __ ] beauty
he's falling asleep oh my god get up get
up let me see eyeballs go like that
it's late
no i'm not tired
we got [ __ ] up about an hour before we
started
you know i'm rarely the sober guy in the
room man i'm rarely the sober guy in the
room you are tonight
it's a nice change so now you started at
denver
no i didn't have a chance if you don't
have an offensive line for peyton
manning by the third
third week of preseason you're a [ __ ]
idiot you know what i mean and they had
they had great they had two great guards
they had a they had an okay center and
the tackles were were both really solid
so they were lined up and peyton's you
know the offense
is
it's complicated and it and it makes it
more complicated for offensive lineman
so like
where my mindset was because i was so
worn out i'm just like man [ __ ] this
[ __ ] this whole system [ __ ] all of it
you know what i mean and that was it i'm
like i'm gonna show up to work i'm gonna
clock in my hours
and i'm gonna go home and smoke this
colorado [ __ ] and that's all i'm gonna
do
and that that eventually hit like a
point of like
[ __ ] even that you know what i mean and
then it was like that was it and that's
when i eventually just
packed it in and left no i couldn't do
it i couldn't do anything just like yeah
retired i couldn't do i went back home
to seattle on the bye week
and uh
i just couldn't do
[ __ ] weapon went back to seattle
had a whole week bye week right it was
with my girlfriend [ __ ] you know
hanging out whatever took a ton of
mushrooms okay
about four days before right like i had
to go back i'm tripping my balls off and
i'm like doing the whole like put life
in perspective put your whole world in
perspective and i was like no it doesn't
work it doesn't [ __ ] work for me come
down got a day or three to like be real
normal get normal for a day or two still
feel the same way even though i [ __ ]
my head up that it was on on a mushroom
trip that i pretty much said i'm gonna
quit the nfl right and god forbid i tell
any could you imagine telling some espn
[ __ ]
yeah i dropped some mushrooms that's
what i should have said though that's
what i should have said right off the
bat because they couldn't get their
heads past
you're walking away from a million
dollars and it became all about that
[ __ ] you know you came all about like a
million and then i had to do this whole
like oh you know but the reality was
like i really wasn't happy with what i
was doing i was like at a point where
you know
where you're just like [ __ ] it and i
feel like everyone's gotten to that
point you know some point at some point
you get to that point once you see
something for what it is and you just go
what's the point of doing this [ __ ]
exactly
lee hit it [ __ ] sucking a little tony
bennett on a monday here just to break
up the show a little bit you're on
[ __ ] fire you're great man
it's easy
here real quick we'll move this right
along
always waiting for dust my main man
renaen carcione
tim woody noah
no north shore scott jason segens
naughty nate nasty nate whatever your
[ __ ] name is mr gonzo kern michael
constantine reign and my main man juan
vargas i love you [ __ ] stay black
we're here talking to my main man john
moffitt
you retire you get to seattle how do you
end up in l.a
oh my god well the first time i ended up
in la was for rehab okay because i went
to malibu passages which was weird as
[ __ ] because when i was on my little
bender i kept seeing commercials for
that dude yes i was an addict for 10
years who gives a [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
thank you you guys go another 10 15
years before you can open up a rehab i
could open up a rehab you gotta work
yourself to that [ __ ] position we hit
the air conditioner we're sweating up
the storm in here really i'm freezing
do you see me yeah me too yeah get
together you're slipping there's a
[ __ ] steamboat
i'm freezing so you go to rehab you get
your life together yeah so basically so
uh
so when i finish i'm i'm like i mean
when i left i was literally i was being
so blunt and honest as possible i'm like
look i'm just not happy i don't like
this [ __ ] i can't do it right
and uh there was no like plan b
there was no like oh i'll go into this i
had no clue i had no clue what i was
gonna do so i was like i like radio
stuff i like this maybe i'll i'll just
go that way
um so thank you brother yeah thank you
i'm good i'm good no he might need a
water yeah let me get a water please i'm
good i'll be peeing through eating the
[ __ ] morning
i'm freezing cold how can you be
freezing cold it was a hot day today now
and it's cold day today in l.a
look at lisa little flying jew look at
the physique he's a savage
that's a physique i just wanted my first
seder out here too
yeah i'm sorry
that's the worst one for jews that was
the food it was terrible is it that's a
bad one no they i mean they like the
brisket is good but like there's no
bread it's all mata which is disgusting
nobody's nobody's eating carbs no the
jews don't like cups
and then you can't have like you can
never have like shrimp or anything with
like meat and cheese on the same dish
that's [ __ ] up it's a [ __ ]
nightmare you know muslims separated
everything yeah i thought it was just
cleanliness but no it's godliness you
have to have everything separate plates
dishes
interesting from now you go to rehab you
come out
now yeah i'm clean yeah yeah and it's
been a year it's been a year so uh
i basically hit like a
after i left how old are you now 28.
you're a young [ __ ] man yeah you
still got the world by the balls that's
what i keep telling myself right thank
you yeah yeah i feel good i feel really
good so and you're unbreakable with dave
yeah yeah how the [ __ ] did you end up
unbreakable with that savage so i was
kind of part of like a cleaning up and
changing [ __ ] up i was like all right i
kind of want to
train a little bit again i think you
know when you
i left the nfl and then i went through
this you know like just a bender just a
great party thing that climaxed in
chicago got arrested how long was it
well
the it was a bender within a bender but
the intense bender within the big bender
was six weeks and it was six different
cities
and it was not i got kicked out of the
house basically like i couldn't go home
in my home in seattle we were on me and
my girlfriend around like the no go
so
i went to like miami las vegas new york
chicago
uh
la and then back to chicago for seeing
an atm car with a smile on your face i
was still getting paid for playoff games
[ __ ] yeah the denver broncos went to
playoffs and they were giving me playoff
checks [ __ ] yeah oh it was it was like
like a doctor buy me a drink and give
that guy in the corner a drink too
give all these humps a drink peyton
manning scoring touchdowns it was i was
like the big
and then and then on top of it like
betting on the games too yeah you don't
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i'm out i know all
this [ __ ] i've scouted all of it right
so i get the checks and then turn it
around a little or just go blow it
somewhere and uh
luckily my my financial advisor that i
had when i was playing still had like
that but this money was all like
unaccounted for [ __ ] you you know i'm
kidding and every week in the playoffs
you get a new check
get a new check it's like 20 grand oh my
god every week one was 40. you're just
like what the [ __ ] i came home to check
out i didn't even know it existed i
couldn't believe my girlfriend even told
me she's like there's a check in the
drawer [ __ ] you i'm like oh
so i was so i went out and hit all these
cities and then i finally climaxed in
chicago because i had like like the
alchemist i had like six different kinds
of drugs on me to hit all these
different points and i finally got to
the point where i was like when your mug
shot picture is like the worst one
in the world you know what i mean like i
i get in front of i'm all [ __ ] up they
they don't tell you you're taking a
picture next thing you know look up
right you have one second to think about
it and i'm like look innocent for the
judge that's my that's the thought that
comes looks it which makes no [ __ ]
sense at all makes no sense at all right
clearly a drug thought so i do i have
this like puppy
dog sad pathetic mug shot that's just
[ __ ] horrible and when i saw that i
was like oh my god i'm going to i'm
going to [ __ ] rehab delayed that for
two weeks of course and then finally
went to rehab in april
so it's been a year now and then like
when you get out you know when you quit
all the drugs you're on and everything
your mind is just like different oh my
god so you don't really know what you
like
hey what do i reject what do i not what
do i actually believe in what do i not
scary yeah first 90 days when you're
sober is a very scary thought because
you haven't thought clear no you haven't
felt clear in years i got locked up by
the fourth month i was thinking tip top
i'm drinking water yeah i'm eating
wonder bread i'm getting three squares
i'm sleeping nine hours your mind comes
back and you even start
questioning yourself like where have i
been yeah where has you know john been
where has joey d has been
you know could you have like stayed
under contract and just gone to rehab
and then like not had to retire it took
me
um
they're quitting like they're separate
things and then and then sometimes you i
think that they could be connected the
[ __ ] up thing that the thing that
annoys me is that when i quit it was
very public because i was like hey maybe
i'll do radio i'll do some interviews
and i'll say that on twitter it actually
worked i had two offers up in seattle
for like do you want to do a show or
this or that but they want to talk about
sports and i was like hey [ __ ] sports
like i can't do it i can't do this [ __ ]
anymore so that i kind of steered away
from that but
when i quit i really was like i'm not
i'm not doing this and then obviously it
was i kept finding things i said
blatantly like i'm very unhappy with
what i'm doing i'm not happy in life i
need to change it so classically you're
not happy just do a bunch of drugs and
that leads to the next thing is chicago
yeah exactly
so whether one played off the other one
was with the other
whatever you know i mean that's kind of
the situation but i think it needed me
like there was no way i was ever going
to go to john elway and be like hey i
need to go to rehab
we're on a super bowl run but i gotta go
to rehab right now and that was the
other [ __ ] up thing i was like
um
both my teams were in the super bowl
that year the team i got traded from
we just played when i got we played the
denver broncos i was in seattle in a
preseason game i got traded to [ __ ]
denver bull browns and then denver and
that was their first meeting since
getting their asses kicked by seattle
that the team i was on and elway's in
the front yelling at everybody and i'm
in the back of the room like jesus
christ this is weird and then they go
play each other in the super bowl which
was like the other bizarre thing which i
was like [ __ ] i should really sell both
of these playbooks i wish someone i was
waiting for someone to contact me
to [ __ ] i will give you all of the
plays and i'm pretty sure i told on
omaha like i was in an interview like
early on and i was like yo everyone
understands omaha's when peyton's like
going to snap the football right and
then after that it became like i'm not
saying after that me the guy says it all
the [ __ ] time all the time i would
have given him everything
you miss it
yeah a little bit i do i miss i miss the
uh
this is what you've done since you were
how old
eight years old every time a [ __ ]
leaf comes down yeah every time july
comes what do you think about that's it
i gotta go lift weights i gotta eat good
i gotta yeah
i still remember when football season
would come in the neighborhood you could
always tell how
the guys are going to play football how
they changed a little bit they started
running laps you know
and and you have to miss that it's a
part of who the [ __ ] you are you know
you know it's so uh
it's kind of i've always said
that playing in a football game is just
like getting high
because the whole process is like very
similar like you you and science has
even proven that football players are
addicted to adrenaline most football
players have adrenaline spikes that are
like crazy
but you know you go in you're about to
go into the game you're about to play
the game you know you know it's there
you're waiting you're a little nervous
you know what's happened and then you
know you walk out a tunnel it builds
this is building building building
building and then first snap comes then
you're just on for [ __ ] three hours
just going and then you crash after
and then that's it and the and the
lifestyle too the extremism and
lifestyle where i could be like all
right party party party party
okay clean up clean up now it's football
time clean up play football you know as
good as you could clean up and then okay
party party party put so those two like
that like extremism
you can see it matches perfectly with
addiction it matches perfectly with you
know alcoholism all of it really you
know it's it's the same thing with a
comic's life you know absolutely you
have 23 [ __ ] hours to burn you could
read so many books you could jerk off so
many times yeah eventually you know i'm
gonna smoke a joint and have a drink or
something thank god i don't fall into
the drink
category i have nothing against people
who drink i i'm a smoker you know i like
but
anything like that look at
you know jon jones with [ __ ] mma oh
my god you know you live when you're
addicted to something
like i said it's not the addiction it's
how you react how your day goes
you know that's why
i always tell people night when i did
coke i couldn't control my day
i don't know if i'm going to be driving
leasing to cut me off i'm going to get
out and yell at him in the front car and
call him a [ __ ] sucker and he's going to
shoot me i'm going to shoot him back
that's your day
you cannot control yourself i knew okay
let's say i went to miami
let's say i went to miami to do comedy
i get in the night before like tuesday
he has a feature act again monday night
do you think i get that because i cared
about the club no i got there because i
walked right to the club and asked him
for a 100 draw yeah and i called the
colombian and he came over and brought
me a package
so i know if i did blow monday and
tuesday night i had to take wednesday
night off
i knew this as an attic and as a comic
but if i wanted to do good for the
weekend i had to take like wednesday or
thursday off and then i could get high
on saturday night after the third show
and i could go deep because who gives a
[ __ ] about sunday anyway
you know yeah
so i knew when i could that's the same
thing you're saying you know you know
you get high and then there were some
weeks where i couldn't control it
i had one
thing i had one personal rule i did not
get high before i went on stage i smoked
50 joints
i'll take a valium i'll have two [ __ ]
amaretto milks but i will not [ __ ] do
a bump because i knew my timing would be
completely off
that's just me but when i was locked up
i would do speed on monday with these
[ __ ] biker dudes in prison
right and and monday nights we had to
play basketball and i do like three and
i was in great shape then i swam every
day before i got locked up i knew i was
gonna get locked up in colorado so i got
into swimming and lifting and i rode a
bike i didn't have a car i sold the car
and i just rode a bike and i tell you
what i would do six or seven laps with
the meth in me whatever the [ __ ] we were
we would we would snort it yeah and oh
my god i couldn't play [ __ ]
basketball after a while i thought my
my heart was going to bounce out of my
chest it was too much the bow it would
be bouncing along by itself why do i
want to be running laps like a [ __ ]
yo-yo
is it can you guys like explain just
because like for me i'm like the
straightest guy ever i know now i'm
super high but like i've like i don't
have anything in my life that would have
like that what i would do that would
hurt me so like for someone like me on
the outside who let's say you're a
headlining comedian or you're in the nfl
like why like it seems like it should
have been an easier decision to like
just not do it but it just seems like
it's just not even a decision
you just explained it lee
you got to turn that animal off
it's very tough
it's very tough there's some guys you
played with that didn't say two words
correct yeah yeah they went home
afterward they [ __ ] their wives yeah
they went hunting they went fishing they
shoot tobacco yeah that's what offensive
linemen do then there's the other half
of the offensive alignment
where they can't turn that [ __ ]
blocks off they go home and they're
still seeing themselves shuffling their
feet they count and shuffle
they start counting [ __ ] shuffles and
[ __ ]
you know and that's what everything
anything that listen man it's tough
having a 9-5
it's tough driving the 405 and thinking
about your kids can you imagine playing
in front of how many people on the
weekends
80 to 100 okay somebody always at your
door knocking
it's about money dog you got two weeks
to get your life together it's about
money it's not about high school no more
the coach don't give a [ __ ] who's here
to see you you don't perform somebody
else come in and do the [ __ ] job for
you you get hurt you got to sweat it out
a little bit
you got to go back and there's three
guys now that know you're hurt and
they're doing push-ups and they're
eating spinach and they're [ __ ] doing
that thing it's pressure man
and sometimes money is too much pressure
for people yeah i love doing stand-up
you know when i hate it
when i get paid
really i hate it i [ __ ] hate the
whole thing i don't want it to be a
chore yeah i want to be sitting here
with you right now you know what bro
what are you going to do after let's go
get some wings there's a stage i'm going
to crack some jokes
and that's how i make a living they give
me a guaranteed 25 bucks or something
i'd be happy
but when i got a fight with people and i
can't even you know i i thought you
played football in the back of my
[ __ ] mind you went to college you got
your dick sucked you got a [ __ ]
degree okay you got drafted and you went
and they gave you a playbook and you
play football no they give you 200 pages
of [ __ ] things to read and team
conduct and nfl rules a [ __ ] that you
can and you can't do and you start
looking at this going i thought this was
football this is mild communism
for a [ __ ] paycheck they want me to
do it and okay i understand the code of
ethics and i understand a lot of things
but in today's world it's completely
different well isn't didn't goodell like
really tighten down everything that's
what i heard like when goodell came in
just made everything awful it's a
corporation now yeah they're making
billions of [ __ ] dollars but guess
what he has a bad game
he misses
a block
i have the right now to go on twitter
and call him a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what i have to write off
because i either i'm a fan of seattle or
denver's or cleveland
i have the right so how many times can i
call him a [ __ ]
on twitter before he comes home one day
you know he has stress his job he hurt
his knee before he goes hey [ __ ] you too
you fat [ __ ]
now guess what 2 000 people see that and
they show that to the seattle seahawks
this is a different code ethic and now
the internet adds more to it you know i
used to go on a set of a movie
you went you ate you smoked a joint
now you're going to sit in a movie and
you're signing 10 wave is telling you
don't take a picture and put it on
social media
don't do this don't do that so shooting
the movie is becoming something else
okay yeah i like the money and the whole
thing but excuse me it's becoming
something else
and that's what i didn't like about
football like i don't understand about
that's what i learned when i had when i
did the longest shot yeah because i
talked to brian bosworth
yeah brian bosworth is the [ __ ]
essential nfl you know oh yeah and he
wasn't a a drug guy enough and now just
had issues in the other level and he
didn't like it and he went head to head
with them and you know some people go
you know what i'll take this model
communism i'll support my family and
keep my [ __ ] mouth shut but then you
get guys like you that are great guys
you're a sweetheart but you know what
[ __ ] after the game i want to go
out and [ __ ] cut it up a little bit
yeah you know what years ago i have a
tight friend who's in bind right now
today he's in a big blind right now he's
looking at some jail time but for a
while he thought he was a real badass
nice kid i grew up with my loving like a
brother
he was bouncing one night at a bar
i'm [ __ ] coked up out of my gills
i'm 60 yards away from this bar there's
a big parking lot
i get i look at my friend i go hold on i
take my dick out and within 10 minutes
this kid i grew up with says what are
you doing
and i'm pissing meanwhile his jaw's
going he did two bumps my jaw's going i
thought all was forgiven and for two
years he ratted on me
about to pee that time he not ratted on
me he broke my balls every time i'd see
him he'd go you have no class b
like he got so insulted from the beat
kill this day i could see if i pissed on
your door on your mother's leg on your
cat but i'm peeing in a parking lot yeah
60 yards from the door
i don't you know uh
seattle was one of those places where
they took everything very literally the
police department yeah to the t
even if you told the cop like i'll be
seeing you again brother he'll go uh you
threaten me no no no i can do comedy
yeah i know your partner goes in that
comedy club i don't know you might have
let me go discuss this some people just
take [ __ ] [ __ ] literally man
that's true that's [ __ ] up that it
could be like
there's so much discretion like somebody
like if you did that here would you have
gone to jail or what do you like would
have that have happened well you know
like in a big city like i said there's
more
there's more leniency
there's more understanding we don't have
time to give you a ticket for [ __ ]
jaywalking and you know what i
understand i understand that's a law bro
and i didn't know and all you had to do
was pull me over with your three because
there was three guys on bicycles
so i was mesmerized by the whole thing
they just rolled up take it from a guy
in a [ __ ] bicycle yeah like if they
arrested you they put you on the
handlebars or something i i don't get it
i'll bend those [ __ ] things
my brother what are your plans you're
sober you look healthy you're getting
healthy what are you playing you're 28.
you got the world by the balls i know
you know i'm just uh i decided to come
down here and get in shape and kind of
uh
kind of find a new direction but really
i'm just kind of keeping it easy i'm
still working out and training so i'm
considering it you know i mean i'm
considering possibly
doing more with the athletics or
something like that like you say
athletics like i'm gonna go on a [ __ ]
dodgeball right but uh you know it's
it's kind of like
like i said uh like before when you get
out of rehab you kind of realign your
whole world you know i mean as it as
it's as it's gone it kind of more
changes in real life so i take it you
know one day at a time i don't plan too
far out you know and then kind of see
where it goes honestly
that's all you could do man
just being sober like when you uh
when you're young and you like to party
like you when i was 25 i did not
understand people who didn't party no
and i'm not the guy hanging out with
lionel richie at a club dancing on the
ceiling i'm not that guy i party that
word meant nothing to me i just didn't
understand what
how in my mind partying was to break
down my mind i looked at it that way i'm
gonna grab a blow a couple beers and go
home and i think about [ __ ] and i'll get
my dick sucked later on and make some
call whatever yeah whatever you went for
in those days and i was just counting
myself it was the addiction
i remember the first year off below
while i was talking to you
the [ __ ] i went through this is just six
seven years ago i'll be a sober this
november eight years from powder nice
and that first [ __ ] year was a mind
[ __ ] up
because i didn't i always told people i
wasn't gonna do it anymore
but i just didn't know for sure
yeah but then as the months
as the months progressed every day that
i got sober
i thought about how i acted when i was
sober and now i could see the change
like all of a sudden i had money in my
atm account like yeah oh my god i'd have
[ __ ] money in there like how much is
it now 280 280
having that 280 in my [ __ ] bank
account in [ __ ] year
my bank account was between 32
and 100 hours at all times i was a grown
[ __ ] man
you know
it's something that uh
i do i can't even imagine today doing a
blast yeah i love my reefer you know i'm
52 i'm settled already brother yeah i'm
not gonna quit briefing them it's too
late no it's true
and i think it honestly i i think i
think it's good to ease off of
everything else honestly because you you
know it and you know what it can do like
i used it to ease off of everything and
uh
i think it's like a lesser you know like
a lesser evil lesser evil of all the
evils you could do listen i'm not going
to knock on your door
at four in the morning to borrow 50
bucks
i'm not going to get a you know i'm not
going to uh
look out the window all [ __ ] night
i'm not going to put my family out of
[ __ ] business because i want a smart
blow
this reef is [ __ ] i got into it when i
was like 12.
and i always liked the one aspect of it
that helped me sleep at night yeah i
really enjoyed that and it makes
doritos taste oh jesus like [ __ ] god
you understand and everyone's a lot more
interesting too that's like half the
reason i feel like i well no let's be
[ __ ] honest that's like one percent
of the reason why i probably used
everyone just gets so much more
interesting you know i mean you deal
with all these people that's the thing
like
when you play in the league you talk
about like the twitter accountability
you know and i find football players are
like the like some of the few people in
the if you call the entertainment
industry that actually have to
really pander and cater to fans and
still put on this like you can say
whatever the [ __ ] you want a football
player still has to be like oh good game
tonight and you know god bless and you
know love jesus and all the right things
you know i mean still like has that
political kind of
aspect to it so i always found when i
was playing because i had to be so
[ __ ] fake all the time you know god
forbid i offended a fan that came up to
me in a bar
much easier just to get trashed and just
not worry about it you know what i mean
or just be like wow [ __ ] it whatever
you're saying is fine you know it
doesn't really
resonate with me or you know it's not
interesting but people fans like you in
your trash yeah they want to see you
[ __ ] up at a bar they want you
to know that you know you you bleed when
you cut yeah i noticed that at 20s i
used to see a lot of the
seahawks and then the fans really like
it you know i mean
you don't want to be pissed drunk and
john and coke rocks falling out of your
[ __ ] nose
but you know people uh know yeah at
least tip did they glass and can i send
you a drink over and oh yeah it's it's
it's a
man it's a great honor to be a
professional football player man you had
yeah man it was a very fun ride it was a
wild ride it was a wild ride it was a
fun one though you're a wild dude i
can't tell by that smile that smile
listen man i hope you uh
find love and peace and everything
you're looking for thank you once you
get off that [ __ ] it's there you know i
have a friend that drinks
and i can't call her anymore and bust up
balls i don't i i would never bust
anybody's balls because i never liked
people busting my balls you constantly
bust balls but i wouldn't buy somebody's
balls about getting high okay i know
there's a problem exist i'm not going to
change their life by talking to them
it's some a conscious decision you got
to make it yourself to make it yourself
you could get blue in the [ __ ] face
telling me how cocaine's going to kill
me joey you love me stop for your kids
they're going to put you in jail
all you got to do is drive me you'll get
a [ __ ] package that's all you're
doing by talking to me about that [ __ ]
is making me [ __ ] want to go get my
car all
but it's right
morning you wake up and you go you know
what i hurt my dad yeah i hurt my mom i
i hurt myself more important i hurt
myself bro yeah and you know what you're
right [ __ ] football [ __ ] everything else
right now it's about taking care of you
whenever the [ __ ] you land you're still
a young man you got the world by the
boss thank you for coming in hey thank
you so much for having a [ __ ] savage
give a shout out to your dad i got it i
got to give a shout out to dave moffa
he's a huge fan of yours man he's been
telling me about you for two years now
they live in connecticut they live in
connecticut
i call yeah
my mom and i called him up uh
just on the way over here and he didn't
know
like i texted him and i and i said hey
i'm i'm going on diaz's show but i don't
think he like got across right and so
i'm telling him on the way over here and
he's like are you [ __ ] he's like what
are the chances i tell you this that's a
small world yeah for two years now
you're on a show i've been listening
you're the only one you know the podcast
you're the only one you're like
i wanna give them a shot i'll send them
my love and stuff i will and uh yeah
you're down there with dave and
unbreakable which is great oh yeah
that's amazing jim he did youtube yet no
just stretching oh my god just
stretching just like that long-legged
[ __ ] he looks his hands are like
they look like they could go through a
wall just straight you know like he
looks like i wouldn't want to jiu-jitsu
him i feel like he [ __ ] you up you know
he's a strong guy he knows what he's
doing he's a little older he's got that
old man's strength yeah but he's a great
[ __ ] trainer yeah he really really
knows his [ __ ] man
every time i go there i learned
something new from him absolutely i was
telling lee i get a 15 pound dumbbell in
my trunk and i go to no ho park and i do
sit upstairs they're his synapse they're
the ones he taught me for jiu jitsu
where i just get it and do a sit up and
kick my legs up and go back that's all
dave's [ __ ] dave's got a thousand things
oh yeah i went to jiu jitsu and i i did
one of the tricks he taught me where
neon belly and you switched the leg so
you can't get your leg caught and the
guy goes would you learn that from sean
i go better yet one of his brown belts
yeah and he's like that's who teaches
that [ __ ] dave's a
a bad [ __ ] thank you again thank
you
hold on one second there let's give a
shout out to my main [ __ ] over
there at on it
alpha brain [ __ ]
complete earth gone nootropic you
understand me you're [ __ ] up you can't
get your heads cleared
alpha brain is the way to go 30-day
money-back guarantee we don't even want
the product back who does that [ __ ] you
know your drug dealer and you i didn't
like your [ __ ] heroin and i get my
money back and then they give me your
money back [ __ ] no you did it [ __ ]
sucker on it don't care when somebody
does that that means they care about you
and they can means they care that they
want to do business with you
if you don't like that product 30-day
money-back guarantee okay and that's
what the alpha brain their flagship
[ __ ] product go down and right
go to on it right now take a look at all
that great products go to the box and
press in church boom 10 off like a
[ __ ] just like that
also they have to stay on a program
where the mail is stuffed right to your
house on a monthly level you can't lose
whether it's the shroom type sport the
shrimp truck and moon immune the new
mood the new tea formula the
testosterone enhancer whatever the [ __ ]
it is the hemp force protein the acai
vanilla or the chocolate you're not
gonna lose go to alpha brain go to
honor.com right now
my main people over there at
irondragontv.com
as you notice i'm a little [ __ ] up
tonight that's what happens when you
read a couple green hornets and the last
piece of the jewish star of death
this thing was huge at one time
look at the size of this [ __ ] juice
star at deck look at this [ __ ] thing
there ain't nothing left [ __ ] suckers
what happened i was zooming in so you
can see it oh sorry about that he took
the [ __ ] world in there anyway go to
iron dragon tv for classic martial art
films these films are the best martial
art films you always want to get into
[ __ ] there's no ufc there's nobody
[ __ ] slapping one
nobody what are you gonna do you're
gonna sit there and watch [ __ ]
dancing with the stars [ __ ] no go to
irondragontv.com right now to watch
classic martial arts films from the yet
man series to the kung lee series
i'm
i don't know whether they exist or not
but their movies are at irondragontv.com
right now you understand you get two
free movies when you say the name joey
joey j-o-e-y that's how we roll two free
movies iron dragon tv roku technology 4k
they're a leader dave foley putting [ __ ]
together over there but don't listen to
me go to
irondragontv.com right now take a look
at that great [ __ ] classic martial
art films you got two of them coming on
me go to the box and press in jerry boom
and get two free films 86 ain't [ __ ]
around this month
1200 guaranteed pups it's may 17th you
know when i brought this [ __ ] up
here at the beginning of march
1200 [ __ ] pups he's giving you five
of these things for fifty dollars at ten
dollars a piece whether it's a cigar
whether it's a hidey sig whether it's a
24 milligram the zero ton
start right now this is what i would do
if i was you [ __ ] dummies it's
summertime you didn't quit in january
right here's your chance for 50 [ __ ]
dollars dummy for 50 [ __ ] dollars you
mow moist you'll never smoke again you
get yourself to 24 milligrams the 16
milligrams the eight milligrams of the
zero and you're gonna get yourself a
cigar so you look like a doctor this
weekend memorial day you're getting a
little party with your little red shorts
on you won't look like you're doing
something like an interesting dude look
at him he ain't smoking a cigar he's
smoking a heady sick [ __ ] cigar 1200
guaranteed pops they last longer they
taste better than them [ __ ] hindu e6
if they sell you a 7-eleven go to 86
right now and get your [ __ ] what do
they get
you go to joey's church president joey's
church and you get five for fifty five
for fifty and if not you get twenty
percent off right that's all i know also
listen
joey i don't wanna want i don't wanna be
healthy i don't wanna watch colorful
movies i don't to smoke no [ __ ]
electronic cigarettes all right what do
you got for me you know what i got for
you
if you're a wax smoker or oil
oil let's say you like rubbing oil on
your feet and smoking [ __ ] wax with a
[ __ ] vapor pen
nail their life is here for you cops
suckers go to nailed it life.com and
look at the beautiful supply no the one
vapor pen they have twenty percent off
it's fifty dollars you get it for forty
dollars and it's guaranteed you have a
problem with your pen the coil breaks
it's not getting charged you call dave
and within 24 hours he's got the piece
for you sometimes it's not the price
it's all about the customer service i
don't care about how many eight balls
you do the night before i care about how
you suck my dick the next day at the end
of the day that's all we're worried
about go to honor.com
dragontv.com well then the live
presidential deals kittysigs.com and
nailed it life.com they're great
companies they provide a great service
thank you very much for supporting us
again john moffatt bad [ __ ] you
know you could talk to him on twitter on
where uh moffat74 if you want to help
him whatever you do let's say you you're
into
staying clean you want to hike around
moffitt's always there on [ __ ]
twitter you know facebook
yeah yeah i don't really do the facebook
just go to twitter twitter and if you
smoke dope and do drugs stay away from
moffitt don't let me find out you're on
twitter showing me a little raggedy tits
if you're clean and sober and you want
to show them your [ __ ] he's available
listen no vegan [ __ ] smells like
[ __ ] 10 dead iranians that vegan
[ __ ] the ph is off the pussy's all
whacked up
no vegan [ __ ] at this [ __ ] house all
right i love you [ __ ] stay black
one more time my main man john martha
one more time my main man lisa [ __ ]
las vegas this weekend watch that [ __ ]
uncle joey's coming to town if you're a
vegan eat a steak [ __ ] balance off that
little monkey spray
the ice house next wednesday night and
then i'm in oklahoma city where you bad
[ __ ] stay black see you
thursday with auntie dolores you got any
dogs or cats
check in we're going to talk about
[ __ ] cbds for your dog
let's say your dog is [ __ ] stupid or
[ __ ] we'll give him a [ __ ]
treatable and he'll see the devil that's
[ __ ] help me out
you're doing like a pbs like infamous
chicken next week with this tv this
weekend
on thursday
i have no idea i got a ticket to boston
i can't believe it man they wanted so
much [ __ ] money and i also got an
email today for eligibility on tsa i
don't have to check in no more oh [ __ ]
oh did you get your uh
yeah
i guess they erased my police record
[ __ ] we're still going
no i don't [ __ ] know they just
emailed me
that's crazy though it's eight years
though
like would you ever think about it like
10 years ago
what's up like you'd be eight years
older that's crazy i don't know it's
84th notes wrap it up we're getting oh
we're done okay